[Applaudissements]
peut-être ce qui
m'a tire en toi tire en
toi n'est rien que l'autre
verre sans de moi
sans de
moi où m'attendait la
jour
V
se
caché derrière les
portes les
portes du
[Musique]
ciel rien de tout ce qui
m pire en toi pire en
[Musique]
toi n'est plus doux que le
grain de ta peau de
ta
voix dont la magie
provie
dans
Ciel m'en sorcelle et
mescortes jusqu'aux
portes du
ciel
doux
doux d'où
viens-tu oh ma tendre
merveille mon amour
absolu versé par le flot des sortilèg et
des rêves
étoilés sous le grand manège
en
[Musique]
chante
peut-être ce qui me re lit à toi lit à
toi mais d'autre que ce corps don de soi
don de
soi que tu m'enroules
autour
tu
cœur pour l'empêcher de
courir se faire prendre
ailleurs et si tout ce que
j' dort en toi dort en
moi je veux que tu le
ré veill en moi veille
en
toi pour que de la terre
ha
s
l' des pluies de nos
caresses mais un bel
[Musique]
arcenciel